president biden pledged in his
inauguration speech to repair america's
relationship with its allies
one of those likely to be britain so i'm
joined now from washington by dame karen
pierce the uk's ambassador
to the united states who attended
today's inauguration
uh welcome to you this is always a
spectacle this one of course had quite a
run-in didn't it so it was quite
different from uh
from any before but how was it for you
uh well i was just very honored to be
there it was a fantastic
ceremony the young poet was amazing but
i think more than
uh all of the individual components
there was a mood lightning in in
washington
at seeing the orderly transition of
power
and seeing a unity speech from the new
president
and i think after all the events on the
capital
in recent days and the fears that
another mob would descend on washington
i think this was a great antidote to
that it showed american democracy at its
best
the orderly transition of power at last
you could say couldn't you
i suspect many of us will be thankful
for the british system which is
you lose you're out has this doubt do
you think
and the battle about the election result
done real damage to america and indeed
to democracy
i don't think it's done real damage to
america to be honest
america has an almost infinite capacity
for renewal and you heard all that in
the speeches that
were made today i do worry
that countries around the world who
might be fledgling democracies
didn't get the lesson that we would have
wanted
pledging democracies to get from the
last few days of the outgoing
administration
but i think president biden and vice
president harris's focus
on the international focus on america as
the leading force for good in the world
and focus on american democracy will
restore
much of america's reputation and
leadership well i wouldn't normally
quote the daily star to an
ambassador of the realm but their
headline today well that was a weird
dream in front of a picture of donald
trump
is that um or does that in any way sum
up for you the the trump era
um no not really i i was here for the
last nine months or so
of the trump administration but i also
saw it from from new york which was my
previous posting
i mean it's the job of the british
ambassador it's the job of the british
prime minister
to get on with the american president of
the day
and defend british interests and british
values
and that's what we do regardless of
who's in the white house
we're very much looking forward to
working with president biden and
vice president harris there is so much
to do to get covid recovery
underway and get economies back on track
and we really look forward to being able
to cooperate with them on climate
as well as all the bedrock security
relationship that we have
yes i'm going to persist with looking
backwards before i look forwards if you
don't mind
um unpredictable attention seeking we
know
how hard was it for you to get on with
donald trump and his administration
well there were areas where we disagreed
on policy
uh iran would be one climate tariffs
and where we disagree on policy we say
so we speak out
we defend british interests but it is
the job of the british ambassador here
to get on with the american
administration of the day
because fundamentally regardless of
who's in the white house or
who's in government in the uk the
bedrock of the relationship it's a very
deep profound
successful relationship built on
security and defense
built on a common culture and that
always carries us through
so what does your job involve now you as
ambassador is it time to
to get the elbows out get the attention
of the new guys does your competitive
street come out do you think to
to get noticed amongst all those other
ambassadors who are vying for attention
uh it is a bit of a competition i think
that's a fair comment
but at the same time we all want to
cooperate we all want to support
the biden harris administration as they
get their agenda
underway for britain particularly i'll
be concentrating on supporting the prime
minister
and the foreign secretary on all the g7
work
that's where we'll be doing the bulk of
international cooperation
on covid recovery and that also involves
you know looking at technology
bringing democracies and technologically
advanced countries together
it's great to be able to do that with
america and then we'll be putting a lot
of emphasis in the embassy
on climate uh britain hosts cop 26 with
italy
in glasgow in november and now that we
have a biden administration ready to
come back into
the climate agreement the paris
agreement there's a lot we can do
together
and then i think the other priority for
us immediately
is to get a group of vaccines to make
sure that the world health organization
is working well to help us learn lessons
from this pandemic help us avoid future
ones and get vaccines around the world
to developing countries and others well
we've got a picture of uh boris johnson
watching all of this
unfold on television back in london
let's listen also to what he had to say
really congratulate uh joe and kamala
harris on uh on their achievement on
their inauguration
uh today it's a fantastic uh thing for
america it's a
step forward uh for the for the country
it's been through
a bumpy period and for us and america
it's a big moment we've got uh things we
want to do
together uh you mentioned obviously
there's two big
international events which the uk is
hosting uh on climate change and the g7
which will no doubt
help relations also vaccines you didn't
mention
a trade deal there was almost a sense
wasn't there that donald trump was going
to be the great facilitator of that
is it still viable is it on the table
does it
go in the back seat do you think because
joe biden is in office and he wasn't
such a fan of
of brexit where do you start with that
uh well we see the free trade deal as
very much a part of
covert economic recovery you know to be
able to do the deal with america
would be a very good sign of confidence
uh in the world economy
uh confidence between two big allies who
are
allies and partners on on economic
issues as well as security
we will have to talk to the biden
administration now they've taken office
about the prospects for the free trade
deal how quickly
we might be able to progress it whether
or not they would want to
highlight certain elements over others
i expect all that to be very amicable
it's what we call a bespoke
trade deal so it doesn't take too much
bandwidth to get it through congress
but i don't want to be presumptuous
about president biden's priorities
we need to talk to them about next steps
absolutely so there's been some unlikely
friendships forged over the years you
look back to
thatcher reagan blair bush um boris
biden do you think that will trip on off
the tongue in years to come
um i think it's true to say that the
friendship between number 10 downing
street and the white house
doesn't depend on party political uh
affiliation
and i think it's also true to say that
the parties don't match up
uh in the way that people might expect
them to
but it's also the job of the british
prime minister as boris johnson has made
clear
it's the job of the british prime
minister to get on
with the american president of the day
it's very much in britain's interest
to have a strong america leading on the
world stage helping tackle
all these global and other challenges
and we see our role
as burden sharing with that putting our
shoulder to the wheel to try and make
progress